but it's a start that absolutely right
set battle was the rotten head of a
rotten organization but it's the whole
organization that has to change now I
think he should go straight away there
should be an interim president ideally
independent people coming in from
outside to help shape the reform process
and I think we have to start getting
into these questions about where the
World Cup is going to be played in 2018
and 2222 right now we can't wait until
next year because I think clearly that
process was corrupted and it needs to be
rerun and we should just point out that
set blasters not even questioned by
authorities at the moment none of those
allegations actually go back to him what
comes out in the future you know it
remains to be seen but Damien Khan is
just in terms of the wave FIFA operates
through him from Richard cable there
about the Garcia report of course this
was the internal review within FIFA that
wasn't put into the public domain and
the man mr. Garcia who carried it out
said that a lot of that information was
suppressed and he was very frustrated do
you think that that report needs to be
made public yes it does need to be made
public but it also the fact it wasn't
just shows that said bladder was never
serious about reform and therefore him
staying on as president for another
another few months or even until early
next year and the inside team at FIFA
shaping a new reform agenda the same
people that blocked the Garcia report
that would rightly be seen I think as a
wrong move but the Garcia report was
very limited what we're seeing now is
the Swiss authorities using their legal
powers to have a criminal investigation
to use legal forces Michael Garcia
didn't have to go after wrongdoing but
looking at the process moon we know that
seven of the 22 people that voted on
where the world cup should be played in
2018 in 2022 have been forced out of the
football because of allegations of
corruption now one of those Chuck blazer
has pleaded guilty to 10 counts in the
FBI's investigation for money laundering
and racketeering so I think we've got
enough evidence now to say that process
was failed and have been corrupted and
we should be there should be one of the
issues on the table right now it's quite
interesting is it the early reaction to
this still breaking news at Sepp Blatter
is resigned is the fact that you know
we've cut off the head of FIFA now it
will all be ok but Sepp Blatter isn't on
his own in FIFA he has a lot of Pete's
support around and there are a lot of
big high up official figures that have
been in there as long as he has
does it need to be a Salt Lake City
moment like the Olympic Committee where
somebody comes in and investigates
everyone and takes a look at everything
across the board it does and it has to
be led by outside people who are
independent and can act sort of without
any challenge or or questioning about
their motivations too often and FIFA in
the past and we saw this when Blatter
himself together from from avalanche
that it was a kind of inside job it was
the old guard protecting each other
there may be people this could be a bit
like a palace coup at FIFA where the old
guard are thinking which get rid of
Blatter tell him he's got to go then we
will close the wagon circle we will
protect ourselves will ensure the next
president to someone who will look after
us that is the real danger we have to be
on the on the what to look out for now
and that's why I think butters should go
sooner i think there's every chance you
will have to go sooner and this process
will be driven not by fifa by the
external forces that are massing against
them LED particularly by the FBI and the
swiss authorities and of course the
views the football found all around the
world and then i think is their voice
and their pressure that has finally
brought this moment on it was certainly
not one that set Blatter wanted to make
an odd a decision he was going to take
on Friday I'm where do you stand on the
position of the Russia and Qatar world
cups of course they have been awarded to
those countries and investigation is
ongoing as to whether what there was
bribery and corruption involved in those
bids if that's found to be the case I
mean who knows how long the
investigation will take do you think it
should be awarded to another country
well yeah I mean I think it should be a
rerun I think we've got enough evidence
already to say that the process was
clearly corrupted there were there were
people who were involved in it whose
votes weighed the decision you know
who'd be who faced these allegations are
admitted two charges of of corrupt
practices so if the competition should
be rerun now there could be a debate
Kotaro should be allowed to rebid along
with all the other countries that bid
that were part of that failed process be
on a level playing a level playing field
under new rules you know with proper
scrutiny I think that's what has to
happen and we can't wait until spring
next year before we start taking this
also decisions we need to be doing it
now okay Damian Collins thanks very much
features here so nice out thank you